après dimanche 6h bernard voyer un joint
son fils jérôme et s'apprête à courir
son premier marathon
comme lui il y à 39 ans je me suis
toujours dit un jour j'aimerais se faire
un marathon puis quand j'ai trouvé ces
vidéos là dans les archives de
radio-canada j'me suis dit ok c'est je
pense que cette année vous je le fasse
bien bernard voyer bravo félicitations
si bernard voyer champion québécois n'a
pas couru le marathon en 1982 c'est
parce que jérôme est né ce jour-là
l'empêchant ainsi de défendre son titre
ce petit garçon 37 ans plus tard voulait
donc ramené son père à la ligne de
départ
en 1980 le tarif est ici le terrain au
body le site attendait pas garnir
[Musique]
on va être dans les temps on va être là
pour le départ monfils et roger colas
marathon aujourd'hui par mon père
fière de toi merci voilà
wen a pas
jérôme se lance pour 42 km parmi les
dix-huit mille coureurs
[Musique]
au 24e kilomètre à l'intérieur du stade
olympique
berne à arette g20 ça va jamais été plus
loin vers mac sans compétition fait que
jeter la serviette mais c'est dur c'est
vraiment dur conseils de l'expert un
bain l'encan contrôler la deuxième demie
pécho d'or il ya du soleil
[Musique]
les derniers kilomètres sont difficiles
jérôme arrive au fil d'arrivée exténué
tombe dans les bras de son père
il a pu se passer la balle à plus j'ai
fait dans ma vie je sais pas comment tu
as fait ta vie un journaliste de radio
canada qui s'appelle denis lemieux que
j'ai croisé par hasard qui a fait les
derniers kilomètres avec mon pays m'a
vraiment motivé bien aidé à pousser
parce que je tenterai pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mérite ça jean françois poirier et radio
canada
hamon